tpm paix fêtera sa 10e saison l'année
prochaine et c'est que vous êtes très
nombreux à nous poser des questions
alors on a pu lire des informations sur
la structure de l'émission sur d
éventuels départs sur des arrivées alors
qu'est ce qui est vrai qu'est ce qu'ils
font mais tu oublies dans un instant
pour imposer en appétit les gens voient
aussi sur twitter nous avait posé
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de questions
avant de répondre à toutes les questions
petit récap de tout ce qu'on a entendu
c'est pas la fin de saison approche et
c'est donc l'heure des grandes annonces
pour septembre et des pmp n'échappe pas
à la règle
parmi les nombreuses nouveautés
annoncées pour l'année prochaine dans
ppmv la venue de pierre jean chalencon
le collectionneur découvert dans
affaires conclues sur france 2 va
intégrer la bande à partir de septembre
c'est également le cas de cyrille eldin
ancien journaliste de canal+ qui s'était
fait connaître grâce à son tour décalée
avec ses interviews des politiques dans
la rue parmi les nouveaux talents qui
devrait également figurer au casting de
cette nouvelle saison samiullah ditto un
jeune youtuber très créatif sur les
réseaux sociaux de mangel vie que
certains d'entre vous connaissent déjà
grâce à sa participation à tpm paix
ouvert à tous mais ce n'est pas tout
cette semaine on a pu lire dans la
presse qu enora malagré et à gâteau vous
pourrez faire leur retour dans
l'émission et qu'eric naulleau et karim
zéribi devrait rejoindre la bande alors
qu'en est il réellement
on vous dit tout ce soir
n'hésitez pas nous poser des questions
autour de la table même si vous êtes
même si vous avez des questions olivier
n'hésitez pas oui bonsoir oui j'ai cru
concept vous servir alors oui alors j'ai
cru comprendre les prochaines la grosse
révolution sexuelle l'émission serait
découpé en trois parties très distinctes
et nous du coup on aime beaucoup bosser
mon sera dans quelle partie
alors les déjà vous dire si c'est vrai
ou si c'est faux qui se sera en trois
parties distinctes est vrai qu on aura
une partie très jeu très divertissement
au début après partie média est ensuite
partie débat voilà et vous serez banon
va vous serez dans toutes les parties
les trois a les mêmes sont bloqués au
fond des trois partis oui mais même
chronique il y aura des entrées des
sorties y aura un bas y aura un banc
avec des remplaçants a ses entrées du
numéro 12 au match numéro 14 maxime
voilà non mais donc voilà nancy est vrai
que vous ferez pratiquement gratuite lui
oui non il aura pas trois oui c'est
pénible
enora malagré c'est un peu l'arlésienne
mais je pense ça fait deux ans qu'on
annonce son retour même pas l'heure pour
les spéciales pour les prime et où est
ce que oui ou non elle va revenir ce que
vous voulez contacter qu'elle soit on se
parle on se parle beaucoup en ce moment
enora pour l'instant c'est c'est on se
parle alors là on vit peut-être de
retrouver pour les dix ans à l'est je
pense qu'elle se dise ce serait marrant
de revenir voilà et on en parle c'est
pas impossible c'est nier c'est non
c'est pas signé mais c'est pas
impossible
voilà on en parle tous les deux on
essaie de trouver la meilleure formule
et si elle revient elle viendra vous le
dire elle même dans l'émission voilà oui
bonsoir j'ai un verdez karim zéribi et
eric naulleau vont venir pour la
troisième partie de l'émission dit ont
d'abord est ce que c'est vrai et si
c'est vrai et ce qu'ils ont été faciles
à convaincre pour venir dans touche pas
à mon pot alors eric naulleau lui sera
la toute l'émission puisque nous rejoint
dans tpm pays et il va faire d'autres
choses vous le savez avec nous puisqu'il
aura sa propre émission également sur
ses 8 et eric naulleau donc ce sera la
toute l'émission et karim zéribi viendra
nous rejoindre en fin d'émission pour la
partie débat voilà et il sera avec nous
pour les 25 dernières minutes trente
dernières minutes de l'émission dont
karim zéribi et eric naulleau rejoindre
bien tpm paix voilà oui oui est ce que
ça sera toujours tes pmp ou bien ça sera
trois noms différents et ce qu'elle
présente la dernière partie ça sera ça
paiera btp pas du tout non ça va
s'appeler tpm pont d'arc atp médias tmp
débat car là vous voyez ça change pas
exclu des chroniqueurs sont venus vous
annoncer qu'il ne souhaitait pas
continuer l'année prochaine
non pour l'instant tout le monde veut
continuer bonsoir isabelle est ce que
l'émission va vraiment commencer à 18h30
cesser les rumeurs qu'on avait pris ne
sait pas encore à quelle heure elle va
commencer mais à risque de commencer
plus tôt oui que cette année l'émission
commence aujourd'hui à 19h10 émissions
risquent de commencer un poil plus tôt
mais il y aura bien sûr c'est que la
télé avant avec valérie benaïm et
l'émission peut commencer
un peu plus tôt oui battu un métier de
leur mot à mot déterminé leader tnt
il ya des rumeurs aussi j'entends ça et
puis par l'ansés circule dans les
bureaux et machin mais contraire tout ça
que tpm paix pourrait être également
décliné le week end
vrai faux seins ça pour l'instant c'est
pas encore dans les tuyaux mais on
réfléchit
peut-être avec la production à une
émission le week-end pour remplacer
thierry ardisson mais c'est pas tes pmp
aux os est d'accord c'est pas maintenant
non merci on est on en train de
travailler on alors parler de certains
chroniqueurs mais il y en a d'autres que
vous n'avez pas annoncée
et que vous avez déjà convaincu de venir
prendre à chaîne déjà on est on est déjà
nombreux donc là là là toutes les toutes
les robes à d'autres annonces ia cyrille
eldin qui va venir nous rejoindre je
vous dis qu'il fera un magnéto tous les
soirs voilà cyril qui est excellent
enfin magnéto sait faire dans la rue
avec les politiques qui sera avec nous
il y aura donc je lui ai dit thomas rogé
de vie qui fera nous une chronique qui a
été excellent chez benjamin qui est déjà
en train de travailler qui nous fera
également des parodies
il ya samuel alito normalement on doit
encore demain que j'adore je trouve
qu'il est exceptionnel et qui fera les
choses dans la rue et ils jouent dit
alors et pierre-jean chalencon à la à
vous expliquer perdant charançon ne sera
pas autour de la table père jean
salençon excès comme sait les dix ans en
fait il y aura toujours nous présenter
un extrait de thé pmp c'est à dire ça
s'est passé il ya dix ans et reliera ça
a une à un fait historique
voilà moi c'est un peu d'histoire ne
fait jamais de mal dans une immersion
oui bonsoir oui ces nouveaux arrivants
et ce qui est des sortants dans les
chroniqueurs alors je les dis un des
nouveaux arrivants on en a parlé des
sortants bah je vous dis on n'a pas la
pêche et lui plein de choses il n'y a
pas de sortant je vous le dit raymond
sera là très régulièrement ce que j'ai
lu dans un torchon que raymond tu es
déjà bien sûr raymond sera là et bien là
bien bien plus que cette année
d'ailleurs encore francesca avait juste
qu'on la dit qu'elle était sur le départ
mais francesca juste elle va être très
très présente chez valérie bénaïm et
voilà il maintenant ce qu'ils font c'est
que date et ne font plus des pmp 1
voilà une personne qui fera d'elle je
voulais vous poser une question puisque
comme vous dites que vous avez démarré
un peu plus tôt ça va prendre un petit
peu sûr mais sûrement c'est que de la
télé donc du coup est-ce que je vais
divisé mon nombre de chroniqueurs où je
peux les garder tous ou comment ça se
passe au g10 chez ton salaire choix du
musée pourra toujours quatre
chroniqueurs par émission est normal oui
matthieu delormeau disponible pour mac
joueurs ce soir
vous aimez bien valoir
j'adore une parenthèse dans la
parenthèse comme il fait tout le temps
d'une visite divertissement il faut on
pense que saddam divertissement c'est un
gars au cas d'une histoire personnelle
un terme qui est extrêmement active est
extrêmement cultivé et c'est vraiment
quelqu'un voilà à découvert moi et moi
vraiment j'ai une tendresse pour ma
gloire mais moi aussi j'aime énormément
aussi magloire 6%
mais oui c'est une bombe et ce beau
conte soir alors j'ai deux questions la
première si vous deviez convaincre
quelqu'un peut-être devenir dans cette
émission quelqu'un qui est connu
aujourd'hui avec tout mais voilà que
quelques aujourd'hui ce serait qu'ils
hommes ou femmes de connu alors
franchement c'était eric naulleau que je
voulais absolument dans l'émission après
après voilà après après je vous dis
après c'est vrai que on avait envie de
faire venir vincent moscato ici parce
que j'aime énormément je m'entends très
bien avec lui mais rmc n'a pas voulu
parce qu'il est déjà sur rmc il voulait
pas qu'il fasse les deux donc voilà
c'est leur choix
et sinon sinon franchement on est on
voilà je trouve que l'équipe est très
très forte déjà pour les 10 ans voila
j'aimerais gg non voilà je voulais
vraiment je voulais dit qu'agathe et
noir reviennent et j'espère qu'elles
vont revenir toutes les deux oui tu es
pmp ouvert à tous aussi en trois parties
le vendredi avec castaldi oui bien sûr
un cast a dit également ce sera parti ce
seront trois parties exactement ah oui
ça change enfin attend bien oui bonsoir
olivier minne solignac de complément la
région accueille ou de temps en temps
voulu et sa voix pour les 10 ans est ce
que il y avait une histoire de film qui
allait peut-être se faire avec ton
équipe
avant que non très bonne question avec
puisque nous sommes en train d'écrire le
film aussi comme un café machin comment
s'appelait tous dit oui le film ppp je
vous dis qui est en train de son annonce
est toujours en projet sont en train de
l'écrire ici et j'espère qu'il tourneras
oreillettes les coulisses on tournera
normalement l'été prochain après ce sont
des comédiens qui vont faire votre rôle
axial
donc on saura qui sera le jean michel
lemaire qui sera la balle et ribéry et
bien sûr vous aurez des petits rôles
dedans pour le clin d'oeil en gain en
temps vous croyez alors les brûler
projet n'a pas compris cette page
oui monsieur mais deux questions très
bonnes questions d'olivier
alors oui il était question de revenir
sur un plateau plus intimiste notamment
le même plateau
non on va changer un petit peu le bateau
ici mais on reste sur ce plateau parce
que voilà il ya pas de notre émission
qui se tourne sur l'autre plateau et qui
économiquement on doit rester ici voilà
je vous raconte tout donc on restera ici
mais on va changer un petit peu le pâté
la deuxième partie j'avais deuxième en
tant que délégué syndical de mes
camarades flickr est ce que selon
peut-être le talent et l'implication de
chacun il pourrait avoir
tertio premier aux dervallières
revalorisation salariale au passage il
perdait vous avez cité des noms est ce
que thierry moreau vous a contacté pour
revenir est ce que vous auriez vous
contacte pas dû venir ou parce que vous
êtes content qu'il ne vous ai pas
contacté pour revenir alors vous êtes
toujours ému il a eu des décisions ce
pas alors thierry brault est très bien
sur lci voilà et il m'a pas contacté je
n'ai pas contacté
la cre avait pas partie des arrivées
voilà que voilà je veux que je te géante
est la seule je vous le dis on est en
contact
voilà historique senora voilà et parce
que c'est sexy pour moi celle qui
représente le plus des pmp débat là sur
des premières années avec valérie avec
le jour ni avec la gare voilà longtemps
qu isabelle s'est passée la question a
été posée en mon absence mais vous trois
heures d'antenne tous les jours vous
allez tenir toute la saison puis savez
vous équiper ses machines à faire le
tennis tout ça non mais le match d'hier
et c'est faire vous inquiétez pas
monsieur énorme ça c'est pas loin de
chez à peu près pareil un béret pareil
que tu me tues ne soignera au pire des
cas à mon père ne tentez pas d'accord
est ce que c'est vrai que jean pierre le
père luc chalencon à père jean
j'embrasse a perdu mais c'est que c'est
vrai saut parce que c'est vrai que tf1
lui a enlevé deux dalles
répond à la question de mathieu qui est
intéressant dossier où il a perdu d'als
à cause de l'émission qui l'a fait ici
non plus voulu qu'il vienne dans tpm
pays je voudrais dire aussi à des
rumeurs comme quoi gilles verdez ne
serait plus dans tpm projet il sera bien
moins gibert delta déjà signé son
contrat on est en train de discuter mais
ça va se faire la main exactement
d'autres questions à nancy c'est tout
est ce que vous êtes très excité par
cette dixième année qui arrive non c'est
pas vous je suis fier bien sûr je suis
très excité par les dix ans karim djoudi
il aura des jeux de foule en train de
faire des constructions pour le début
d'émission aspects de chaque jour et
pour tout les et le plateau pour
justement faire exactement
est-ce que la 10e sera dernier nom en
date la 10e ne sera pas la dernière
je ne pense pas voilà je vous dis il y
aura d'autres saisons derrière et on
sera déjà en train de préparer la
onzième saison derrière mais ce sera la
dixième serait une saison de voiliers
toute l'année voilà je dis oui et vous
aurez toujours les prime la grande race
sera toujours revenir les prêts toujours
et btp sera toujours voilà le jeu de
jeudi soir sur ses buts voilà donc ce
crocodile répondu à toutes les questions
c'est parce qu'à des questions twitter
voilà sur l aider les gens et personnes
des personnes qui voudraient nous poser
des questions sur à entrer parce qu'on a
entendu plein de choses aujourd'hui on
est entêté toujours des pmp dix ans s'il
vous plaît en régie est ce que vous
pouvez vous réveiller merci pour avoir
voilà est-ce qu'il y aura un possible
retour des questions en 4/3
ça manque alors question 4/3 non mais
ont filmé les coulisses sont ces voix là
c'est comme voilà comme c'est fait dans
d'autres émissions qu'il est fait sur
s'est avoué d'ailleurs je vous le dis
dans le prime de jeudi soir vous ne le
savez pas mais ça fait deux mois vous
êtes filmés pendant les pubs et vous
dévoilera tout en jeudi soir en direct
dans le dernier prime de laninon je n'ai
jamais dit ça ses mails ses bonnes
questions déborder désolé nous aurait
les embauches tout ce qui se passe
pendant lehman a indiqué je peux vous
dire qu'on a des révélations à faire
c'est incroyable me sont en race rare
peut venir à tout des rochers avec
valentin qui s'est occupé de ça et je
vous dis ça fait deux mois que vous êtes
filmés
avant toutes ces pubs voilà je voulais
pas je vous le dis on va alors tout
dévoiler
la met en place c'est pas les questions
qui tient sa bouderie qui s'appelle le
téléphone rouge
il y aura quelqu'un c'est la voix de
secret story qu'il m'appellera pour me
donner des infos sur chaque chroniqueur
avec mon âge valable dans la merde
tp sont listés pmp spéciale avec des
fans tout autour de la table toujours
d'actualité c'est gaëtan que j'embrasse
fort que je connais bien il n'y en aura
puisque même et dont ils ont ouvert à
tous ceux ci on mettra aussi des fans 12
est on en train de boire voilà pour
comment intégrer encore plus les
téléspectateurs voilà dans l'émission ça
c'est vraiment important pour nous et je
vous dis l'année prochaine vous ne serez
plus 10 autour de la table mais neuf
voilà on enlèvera une personne autour de
la table basse que demain tu peux
t'arrêter trois secondes sur cette
information
voilà c'est dit comme ça je vous le dis
y'a plus tout le monde allait
prochainement donc quelque chose de fait
julie merci une autre question est ce
qu'on a d'autres questions sur twitter
merci ben apparemment non ils sont en
train de creuser les cherry est ce que
vous êtes expert alors la banque du
coeur ça avance très bien
je vous lis et revanche très bien et
c'est sûr on voulait être prêt avant
juin on y est marié mais on sera prêt en
septembre c'est sûr et certain que la
banque du coeur sera mise en place en
septembre et on fera un grand prime
d'ailleurs autour de la banque du coeur
dès la rentrée je vous le dis il y aura
un autre prime aussi que vous annoncez
un prime spécial hommage à charles
aznavour cc 8 qui a été choisie par la
famille bon vous savez je suis très
proche de jean rachid voilà le gendre de
charles de meaux et ce sera sur s'est
vite il y aura un immense hommage à
charles aznavour avec énormément
d'artistes sera une énorme soirée que
j'aurai la chance d'animer ce sera sur
ses vitres choisissez vite tout le monde
vous le voulez mais c'est c'est chez
nous voilà qui qu'il soit là d'autres
questions les chéris non j'espère que
vous aussi vous des comptes on va faire
le meilleur bien entendu il reste encore
deux émissions avant la fin vous dirai
ce mercredi et jeudi demain on aura le
conseil de classe de tout ce dont j'ai
pas parlé
et vous le dire on aura aussi le conseil
de classe de la chaîne franck à pied
tous voilà pour lui dire ce que vous
avez pensé de la chaîne cette année en
tout cas je vous dis on en train de
travailler à fond pour l'année prochaine
on a passé une année de fou et jeudi
soir le prime
ça va être la folie géraud et
franchement il ya des révélations de ouf
et on voit le vrai visage de chacun